é uma das coisas que mais me fascina é
saber que ao longo da história a gente
como espécie conseguiu superar o nosso
limite biológico de cooperação nos
primórdios do Uno Sapiens a gente vivia
lá em bandos de 150 pessoas mais ou
menos e esse era o número máximo de
pessoas que a gente conseguia colaborar
mas por conta da nossa capacidade de
conta acreditar e disseminar histórias e
imaginar não só individualmente mas
imaginar coletivamente a gente conseguiu
ultrapassar esse limite biológico e
passou a colaborar com milhares milhões
bilhões de pessoas mesmo sem conhecer
todo mundo que ela exemplo as leis as
religiões as nações
os direitos humanos a política nada
disso existe pelo menos no plano
concreto objetivo mas fazem parte da
nossa realidade humana hoje só que tudo
isso só faz sentido se muita gente
acreditar nisso ao mesmo tempo porque
nada mais são do que grandes combinados
que a gente fez como sociedade e isso é
o que garante que a gente consiga
colaborar em massa o poder desta
imaginação coletiva e dessa disseminação
de Histórias Que nada mais é do que uma
fofoca Universal a gente imagina junto
aqui uma história combina de acreditar
nas mesmas coisas espalha para uma
pessoa que conta para outra que conta
para outra e logo o mundo todo conhece e
acredita
a mesma história isso contribuiu muito
para a gente chegar aqui hoje no mundo
globalizado conectado cuja complexidade
é gigante é maluca e aumenta cada vez
mais com o acúmulo de combinados que a
gente vai fazendo como sociedade EA
ciência ao longo dos anos veio avançando
e se especializando para gente lidar com
essa complexidade resolver esses
problemas que foram ficando cada vez
mais complexos mas quanto mais a ciência
avança e se especializa mais complexos
ainda são os problemas que aparecem e
quanto mais complexos eles são mas a
gente precisa avançar e se especializar
na ciência para resolver esses problemas
Oi e aí a gente chega uma contradição
que é aquilo que eu chamo de paradoxo da
alto insuficiência da especialização
Como assim né paradoxo da alto
insuficiência da especialização diz que
essa necessidade da gente especializar
foi importantíssima até hoje e na minha
opinião vai continuar sendo mas ela
acabou tornasse própria insuficiente
para lidar com essa complexidade isso
porque o que deixa o mundo mais complexo
não é só essa profundidade da gente se
especializar cada vez mais e mais em uma
determinada área uma determinada bolha
Mas também como essa área se
a zona influencia e é influenciada por
outras bolhas
é porque a gente enxergando ou não essas
influências existem em um mundo onde
está tudo muito conectado a gente
precisa fazer se conversarem essas
diferentes bolhas e eu sempre gostei
muito mais de promover conversa entre
essas diferentes bolhas do que de fato
mergulhar em uma bolha específica só que
eu fazia isso de uma forma completamente
inconsciente eu sempre fui absurdamente
fã de misturar assunto que que isso
daqui tem a ver com aquilo de lá que que
a mitologia Grega tem a ver com o funk
do Rio de Janeiro qual seria uma
possível conversa entre o Leonardo da
Vinci E além de Gaga sempre sempre por
diversão
e tu tava ali colidindo universos
diferentes e ao mesmo tempo eu nunca me
identifiquei como sendo especialista em
nada isso Até me dava ser uma certa
angústia né Olhava O meu redor
Praticamente todo mundo especialista em
alguma coisa né se aqui tem alguma coisa
de errado comigo não é possível até que
um certo dia um amigo meu chegou e falou
cara descobri aqui um conceito novo que
eu acho que você vai gostar que eu nem
quis Realismo olhei para a cara dele
nessa nesse o que nem que cialista o
termo nexialismo vende nexo e é um
conceito que surgiu em um livro na
ficção científica dos anos 50 cujo nome
que está em inglês the Voyage of the
Space beagle que conta a história de uma
a nave cheia de especialistas por
exemplo em biologia e química astronomia
antropologia e assim por diante e sempre
que aparecia um desafio lá no espaço
nunca Conseguiu resolver sozinhos isso
porque os desafios eram sempre complexos
e multidisciplinares em com atual é isso
e tinha uma pessoa que é o protagonista
nessa ficção que não era especialista em
nada
É mas ele sabia o suficiente para criar
nexo entre essas diferentes áreas e
perceber as relações e as influências
entre elas E adivinha o que é que
solucionava os desafios lá no espaço
justamente essas conexões que ele fazia
e que ninguém mais enxergava porque tava
todo mundo muito focado só na sua
especialidade na sua bolha
Oi e esse é o tal do nexialista que
dialogava resolvia problemas e vivia
colidindo saberes de mundos diferentes
mas também colide em pessoas que tinham
esse saberes então a gente pode falar
que nem que se a lista é a pessoa
especialista no diálogo entre
especialistas isso não se aplica só o
conhecimento científico e formal nada
disso também é saberes informais
e por isso eu me identifiquei muito com
esse conceito de nexialismo Porque até
então para mim era um problema não ser
visto como especialista em nada só que o
que ninguém me contou e eu demorei para
perceber é que não adianta existir só
especialista porque senão a gente cai de
novo no paradoxo da alto insuficiência
da especialização então tão importantes
quanto os especialistas são as pessoas
que promovem o diálogo entre esses
especialistas que são as pessoas
nexialistas que levam as novidades de
uma bolha para outra
Ah e quem mais é que leva informação de
um grupo Plus a pessoa f*********
bom então onde é que se a lista é um
baita de um Fofoqueiro assim como quem
fofoca que ou minha história de um lugar
e Repassa para o outro lugar onexy a
lista também absorve o conhecimento de
um lugar e Repassa para o outro e por
acaso você conhece algum fofoqueiro que
não tem a capacidade de fazer a pergunta
certa porque vamos lá a pessoa que é
f********* raiz ela tem uma habilidade
natural de entender o contexto todo e
fazer pergunta exata para extrair a
informação mais necessária para então só
assim conseguir repassar e espalhar essa
história de um grupo
Oi e essa é a semelhança entre o
fofoqueiro e o nexialismo e a diferença
tá na intenção por trás das perguntas
Cada um faz fofoqueiro pergunta para
saber sobre a vida das pessoas e
nexialista pergunta para resolver
problemas só que quando a gente fala de
problemas complexos a gente vai precisar
levar em consideração o contexto EA
realidade onde esse problema está
inserido quanto maior a complexidade
mais contexto a gente vai precisar levar
em conta e para entender a fundo com o
texto EA realidade aonde a gente está
inserido a gente vai precisar começar
questionar o que tá o nosso redor E por
isso né que se a lista também é um baita
de um questionador da realidade ao seu
redor só que a realidade é um
um mundo de histórias que a gente foi
contando e combinados que a gente foi
fazendo então no fundo né que se a lista
vai precisar questionar as histórias que
fazem parte da nossa realidade hoje em
dia só que vamos lá questionar por
questionar também é muito fácil e pode
não fazer sentido Então a gente vai
precisar entender de onde vieram essas
histórias para conseguir avaliar melhor
Quais delas a gente quer manter e quais
a gente vai questionar para contar de um
jeito diferente daqui para frente e
outras palavras quais combinados sociais
a gente quer sustentar quando a gente
fala de futuros então na minha visão
para a gente criar futuros de uma forma
o mais consciente a gente vai precisar
acessar e aprender sobre o passado e eu
acredito que a gente tem duas fontes de
motivação para criar futuros acessando
passado a primeira é uma motivação
cultural e a segunda é uma motivação
biológica
e esse papo de entender de onde vieram
essas narrativas presentes hoje em dia é
o que eu chamo de motivação cultural já
motivação biológica Vem de um estudo
feito alguns anos atrás por um grupo de
neurocientistas da Universidade de
Washington que usou imagens cerebrais
para concluir de imaginar o futuro e
olhar para o passado ativa um regiões
semelhantes do cérebro toda vez que a
gente imagina o futuro as partes do
nosso cérebro que realizam essa tarefa
são as mesmas que também regulam
Memórias de experiências passadas Ou
seja biologicamente a gente já as
e o passado para vislumbrar e se
preparar para os futuros e é por isso
que eu acredito que esse ser humano do
futuro vai precisar cada vez mais
incorporar essas características
nexialismo assim se colide esses
universos diferentes para lidar com a
complexidade questionar a realidade ao
seu redor mas também Saint use asta da
história e é por isso que eu gosto de me
basear em um estudo feito por um
Historiador britânico chamado Arnold
toynbee fez uma investigação profunda
sobre o nascimento o desenvolvimento EA
queda de várias civilizações ao longo da
história e um fator que contribui
é muito para que todas essas
civilizações chegassem ao colapso foi a
pena da flexibilidade daquelas culturas
ou seja aí capacidade de todas essas
civilizações de reinventar em as suas
histórias e costumes
é isso significa que para uma
civilização se manter viva ela vai
precisar constantemente passar por uma
evolução cultural eternamente
modificando as suas histórias para se
adaptar às novas demandas do seu tempo
só que quando a gente fala de evolução
cultural hoje em dia isso é bem mais
complexo
E por que pediu um lado Sim a gente tem
uma espécie de Cultura Global conectada
a gente consegue se comunicar com outras
Nações com outras culturas fazer
transação financeira a gente tem uma
linguagem comum mas apesar disso por
outro lado os costumes são muito
diferentes então em uma mesma
civilização e um mesmo planeta a gente
tem várias culturas distintas e quanto
mais ela se aproximam e se mesclam maior
é a complexidade da civilização e para
lidar com a complexidade lá no paradoxo
da alto insuficiência da especialização
a gente precisava não só se aprofundar
em uma determinada bolha
e também considerar a influência com
outras bolhas
bom e daqui para frente quando a gente
fala de evolução cultural é a mesma
coisa não vai adiantar a gente evoluir
uma cultura específica ou outra a gente
vai precisar também levar em
consideração Convívio com outras bolhas
que aqui no caso são culturas Em ambos
os casos a gente vai precisar de pessoas
que são especialistas no diálogo entre
essas diferentes bolhas que são as
pessoas nem que se a listas independente
do que são essas bolhas conhecimentos ou
culturas elas são sempre histórias que
foram imaginadas coletivamente e
disseminadas ou focadas por pessoas
e Então apesar do foco tá muito mais na
evolução tecnológica quando a gente fala
de futuros eu ainda confio na história e
por isso eu acredito que o fator
decisivo para a gente continuar
existindo é a evolução cultural e o
desafio no longuíssimo prazo é como
manter flexibilidade da nossa
civilização considerando tamanha
pluralidade né E como imaginar
coletivamente e com Thai histórias e
acolham ao mesmo tempo todas as culturas
em uma mesma civilização
é daqui para frente à complexidade Só
vai aumentar então a necessidade da
gente ser cada vez mais nesse a lista
também vai aumentar
e por isso eu acredito que esse novo ser
humano é nexialista e vive em nexialismo
Oi e esse novo ser humano entende que os
futuros assim como o passado dependem da
nossa capacidade de promover uma imensa
e Universal fofoca